thank you
[Music]
this uh headline is going to have a
couple funky little twists but try to
stay with it canly North Carolina right
a new town manager was appointed and the
cops there were in such a disagreement
with who they appointed that the entire
police force quit Town manager is that
like a mayor [ __ ] police boy how many
people are in the police force that's
what I wanted to know it's like three so
so the entire part time including
administrative positions everything
every person in that building resigned
and all the murderers are like yes
is this like one of those little town
Villages where you just drive through
like you know I've done road trips to
the South and stuff where there's like
four houses and it's the village of
whatever it's called and that's it
yeah yeah yeah yeah let me tell you how
many people that is total seven seven
people four active full-time officers
and in three like office HR the town
itself only has 2 300 people but still
seven people all collectively deciding
resign like what is what it's like also
seven cops holding down this town yeah
that's crazy what do they do just like
go and make their own band you know say
it like they're the criminals too yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah but that's um the crazy
thing is it took me like three different
articles where they didn't even mention
the total models they were just like oh
the whole police worth quit and I was
like how many is that and it looked at
another one they still didn't say still
didn't say then I Googled like oh Kenley
has 2300 people living there yes and the
police force is uh for a full-time
office well for dramatic effect you know
you think if you're from L.A you're like
the hell that's like 40 000 officers
just quit right now
can you imagine that [ __ ] imagine La no
cops
but like what if you were just like a
neighboring town to Kenly and you just
saw that headline and you're like okay
time strike let's go okay maybe it's one
of those towns where it's so small
though that everyone knows there's no
criminals here yeah and everybody's just
in your [ __ ] and we all know each other
yeah but what what what instigated them
wanting to quit that's a thing they
don't say anything well here's here's
the content the only thing context-wise
that I could get is that and of course
this is going to sound obvious the
police department felt like they were
just being overworked because they're
understaffed oh I mean that sounds
pretty oh it didn't matter who was gonna
come in there that was just like the
timing yeah but you know yeah and I
guess the town manager wasn't really in
line with the things that they needed in
order to like remain uh I guess like
satisfied oh he might be doing like like
budget cuts and more hours and less
resources and then the [ __ ] police
chief or whatever is like I can't
[ __ ] work with that [ __ ] yeah yeah
and uh they they didn't say actual
details but that's pretty much what like
they're kind of inferring and so uh once
that time manager got appointed they all
just said Peace like team wow I don't
like local police usually are part of
some sort of a union where they have
collected bargaining and stuff like that
if they were having issues with like
maybe they just don't like this this guy
because whoever got appointed was the
high school bully that all the cops knew
and then they're just you know they got
like small towns got like old beef you
know it's all like big it's [ __ ] big
yeah and he and he won a a prom King and
nobody liked it he got prom King and now
he's the [ __ ] guy that's how it
matter he's all looks like a town
manager no buttheads
out of here who's first to get juice
like all right oh my God
imagine a seven-man March like the seven
people were like trying to protest we're
out of here
how do they rehire that dude who's gonna
[ __ ] join the police force
Department like a whole other piece if
you Joiner immediately promote it to
police
here's a new shirt for Town not in my
town
yeah I guess I'm over here and once
there's like this other town where it
was a small town and there's this
controversy where the police all
resigned and an estate came in so the
state was interesting okay common gear
things yeah yeah so I wonder if that's a
problem I mean that is what happens when
uh isn't that also when City owned
schools or city-run schools like go on
strike they start sending in state
people yeah yeah usually what state was
this in this was in North Carolina North
Carolina a town called Kenly where
there's no cops baby
he said do what you feel kind of place
you know
to be a part of a small town where like
your uncles like the police chief and
then like your mom like [ __ ] runs
this bakery or whatever just everybody
just knows each other's like a big fat
family or whatever right because I've
been in La all my life and you just
don't even talk to your neighbors I mean
I remember that used to be a thing
though it used to yeah it was everyone
knew kind of the block and [ __ ] right
yeah and then I'm like no one wants to
even say hi it's just weird that's why I
kind of feel like that image of what
life is like I feel like that's what we
were supposed to be building towards
yeah and La is just too big of a city
and you know a lot of [ __ ] just doesn't
go that way because when you really
think about things in terms of small
towns everything means more like if you
had like 2300 people right let's say you
had one guy that just didn't want to do
[ __ ] yeah and he's just a bum like
wouldn't you be like hey get up and do
[ __ ] you know but then like if you have
that Village junk yeah in a big big city
when like you know it doesn't really
matter that much it's just like oh yeah
that's something must be just wrong with
that guy but like if you had a village
and everyone's contributing to like one
goal of being a nice town like
everybody's effort matters right that's
very true yeah it's so weird checking in
with each other too that's true yeah
Community is a big thing that's not
showing up hey what's going on let's go
to this house check on them or whatever
yeah it's like being part of a church
that's like really you know very close
that's what I miss about church [ __ ] the
gossip but I I miss the community things
yeah but then man those [ __ ] get so
petty and so gossipy yeah yeah that's
what I [ __ ] hate I think he goes both
ways right like I've talked to folks
that moved from Little cities or little
towns into California and you're like
the small towns are stifling because
everyone's all up in your [ __ ] oh yeah
there's a town Karen oh yeah you know
what I mean and like everyone's judging
you because you know what you did in
high school even though you're in your
40s right now
or whatever like that and you're like
I'm 40 and I'm a professional doctor or
something you know
that's true I didn't think about that
pretty small town I think it was
probably about like 8 000 people but
it's very small yeah yeah so we did have
like uh it's Humble Texas uh where our
humble humble yeah it's spelled like
humble but it's pronounced humble oh and
uh I was there and like uh every you
know even like Elementary School like
I've had the same you know when you have
a homeroom class uh not every year
whatever I've had the same like uh a
couple of friends from pre Pre-K to High
Senior Year that's cool same all right
yeah yeah yeah and still to this day I
have friends that I've known since like
third grade it's also stories like oh
he's doing this now oh that person died
what because this person was this yeah
there's a lot of them you remember first
and last names yeah first last names and
and then like you know uh it's pretty
cool like when people are like damn
Chris Sosa came from Humble Texas like
they kind of have their they do the
whole Hollywood thing for me but it's
pretty cool like but it is those stories
everybody knows everybody at my past
we'll go to Walmart and we're definitely
gonna see it's somebody who I went to
school with or somebody knows my dad's
story and yeah it's a whole stuff and
have that conversation and talk so
that's why in small towns everyone takes
forever to go get out of the grocery
store because everyone's talking the
whole way through everyone's chatting up
what's up what's up yeah
you see that a lot in like Hawaii that's
true it's super dope yeah but I wonder
do you think since you're from like a
town that's smaller is there a higher
care density in smaller towns I don't
hire Karen uh nah
kind of the same ratio yeah I think I
think the Cairns are just they're just
like there yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure
they're evenly distributed even like a
big chip yeah yeah yeah for sure but
yeah the uh there's there's definitely
stories we'll we'll get around and then
also you kind of like you kind of know
the uh the success story of like when
you're when you're from your town like
that you know like they're going to have
a family and then they're going to be
working in the either the power plants
or the oil field in Houston so like the
jobs are kind of like they're gonna set
yeah yeah you kind of yeah the structure
of it is uh like uh pretty and there's
nothing wrong with it but you know you
know that's true if you're in a mining
town it's like yeah you're gonna work
for the mine right yeah that's how it
did uh did your dad grow up in that town
too oh oh no he was uh my my dad my dad
was like from Puerto Rico and then went
to New York and all stuff but then he
ended up like he they when they went to
Houston he was already like um let's say
like 24 25 and me and my mom already
they were young so like he met my mom
when he was living in L.A he was living
in L.A for a bit he was like 21 22 and
my mom was uh uh 21 and so yeah they met
as kids but then they um they went back
his parents were living in Houston
because my grandfather got a job at the
power plants so it was like a select
humble out of Lake all the towns to live
at how'd they say oh um I don't know I
guess the the way that the the market
was because we were actually from a town
like a city
um called Pasadena Pasadena in Houston
in Texas I see in Texas yeah yeah
passing the Texas
they like yeah yeah Pasadena here is
like way nicer yeah president out there
it's called stinka Dina
no you don't say that about my city man
yeah yeah even though we need the same
one hey what the [ __ ] yeah because
that's where the the power plants are so
you can literally smell when you're
getting into Pasadena oh yeah it's a
radioactive smoke
and we've got three eyes I know but yeah
we grew up we grew up in a very like
suburb neighborhood you know saying my
my neighbors I had a white neighbor here
black neighbor here in the crossroad was
an Asian neighbor so I I didn't I I
truly grew up with just different
cultures that just how I was so I didn't
really understand I really I didn't
understand like the racial stuff until
like I've moved to L.A because it was so
heavy be on it that's what people tell
me is like Ellie's not uh Diversified
yeah but like they think uh there's
diversity here because there's a lot of
cultures but what it's so [ __ ] big
that people could just stay in their own
communities yeah never learn English
right whatever or just yeah they're not
mixing yeah no self-sufficient Community
with like been born in America and have
only Mexican friends only Asian friends
whatever it is until they're until
they're [ __ ] like old it's like
without even having one black one white
whatever there's no mixing yeah so
that's the that's the weirdest [ __ ] to
me because in Vegas once I moved there I
was like oh this is a diverse City yeah
like like you my neighbors are all like
different cultures and stuff yeah
there's no like one area that's like
only one race yeah yeah his best
friend's name Skyler really why you
wouldn't have no Skyler best friend over
here
[Music]